Sam Smith is off the market you're not
single right now anymore right now
[Music]
the 25 year old British singer stopped
by The Ellen DeGeneres Show on Tuesday
and opened up about his love life it's
crazy
confirming he's in a relationship
unbelievable unbelievable FYI Smith was
recently spotted packing on the PDA with
13 reasons why star Brandon Flynn
it's weird bringing out an album and not
being single yeah bright in the lonely
hour was so lonely but now I'm singing
songs about this another guy but I'm
quite happy so it's quite weird the
Grammy winner noted that he sings about
that mystery ex in four or five songs on
the new album I'm try not to think about
it too much but the rest of the tunes
are about other men in his life song for
every boy Smith also explained why he
took some time off after winning an
Oscar for his James Bond theme song
writings on the wall my music is about
love and it's important to just take
that time to allow your heart to have it
a little bit